[Music]
I'm Jeff Galore from CBS Saturday
morning welcome to the dish
today we're exploring a variety of
Southern Cuisine from Nashville's Hot
Chicken to Nola's beignets
first up Philadelphia though not below
the Mason-Dixon Line Michelle Miller
found out this restaurant's soul food is
second to none
oh
but I'm just a little player foreign
Club it's about Harmony and
improvisation
on stage
and in the kitchen an experience
carefully crafted by Brothers Benjamin
and Robert Bynum complete with a modern
take on classic southern dishes what is
soul food to you I think every culture
has soul food and I think it's something
that evokes
warm feelings childhood memories time
spent with family I was treated to a
feast reminiscent of my grandmother's
table with dishes like seafood stew
deviled eggs red rice and brown sugar
pineapple bread pudding in all the years
I've done dishes I don't think I've ever
had this much food plated for me I gotta
dig in
[Music]
this red rice is so delicious thank you
so much I appreciate it
oh my gosh Benjamin who has formal
culinary training tries to make these
dishes as healthy as possible Ben used
to be a smoker
how did you know that oh
I quit because I began to feel the
effects of smoking and the effects of
unhealthy eating so he decided his soul
food menu needed a diet too this food is
traditional soul food but it it's rather
like The Stereotype of southern food is
is fried chicken and catfish I wouldn't
have felt right not to do one of those
dishes since it is something that is
part of what we do and it's something
that is part of our history and our
culture but there are certainly methods
and ways to cook food that's full of
flavor that you know you're not pushing
the envelope with your cholesterol and
everything but I'm not going to lie to
you it's a lot of cheese and butter yeah
there is no getting around the mac and
cheese
Benjamin invited me into the kitchen to
make one of Sal's popular dishes the
blue crab toast we're gonna make the
lemon Caper ravagote it's a fancy way
for saying lemon horseradish mayonnaise
horseradish and scallions mustard lemon
juice mayo and lump crab meat on toasted
brioche and then we have our avocado oh
and some lemon
Juice Salt and Pepper and we take that
and we just do a nice little
[Music]
[Applause]
that's our blue crab there it is check
that out look at this I did it all by
myself
you enjoy a nice a nice evening of
dinner and then come next door into the
Jazz Club listen to a set of Music the
front the house is Robert's domain the
Wharton grab mimics the 60-year career
of his late father Benjamin Bynum senior
he owned the Cadillac club which later
became impulse hosting the likes of
Aretha Franklin Nina Simone and Fats
Domino when you think about your dad's
club and what it meant to the folks who
were employed there to the community
that it served what was it that it
provided that
no place else could
the impulse was at Broad and Germantown
which might be considered to be a low
income area and he made a commitment to
the community to have a place that was
upscale elegant and treated people in a
manner that they might not be treated
every place so they really felt like it
was a refuge within the community so
service was really important to your
family very much so I mean it was a safe
haven kind of for us you know we grew up
at that time I was in the heart of North
Philadelphia it used to be called
Yorktown it was uh a challenging area
but I think that um it was a place where
people enjoyed getting dressed up and
going which was a little bit unusual for
those times since 1990 the brothers
picked up the reins with six restaurants
in Philadelphia including Zanzibar blue
opened from 1990 to 2007. you opened the
club when Jazz was on the decline how
much part of keeping that tradition
alive was Zanzibar blue
Philadelphia has a rich Jazz tradition
and we felt like things have begun to
slide a little bit so we were very
committed to presenting upscale
environment with really big names we did
Lou Rawls we did chickaria we've done
Jimmy Scott we've done Nancy Wilson so
we were really committed to bringing
back Jazz to the city of Philadelphia
senior also worked with his sons at
their longest running Eatery warm
Daddies he died at the age of 98. he
handled our door at warmdaddies for for
many many years
he only stops probably a year or so
before he passed away and he was very
much our Rock he was very much who we
relied on to bounce ideas off and to be
supportive of what we were doing so it
was a loss but we still have his legacy
to hold on to the brothers decided to
close warmdaddies during the pandemic
but continue to serve up food and music
at relish and here at South the ultimate
celebration of their father's Legacy
we've been fortunate to have a very
loyal clientele that supports us at all
of our venues so
that's something that is a
been reassuring for us
[Music]
after the break we peek into a top
Chef's Alabama kitchen this is the dish
[Music]
many of us might agree Southern Classics
are as delicious as is but as Jamie wax
found out chef Kelsey Clark has a flair
for adding a Twist to the traditional
fried chicken and champagne is
definitely like the last meal I would
eat before I die probably maybe throw
some caviar on there just in case why
not of all the many places Chef Kelsey
Bernard Clark has cooked the very finest
meal you might get is in her favorite
spot her home but what a beautiful
Southern Home you have it's where we sat
down to an opulent spread of Southern
Cuisine sweet corn with Paprika cheese
and citrus southern biscuits shrimp with
succotash deviled eggs playfully called
wicked chickens one time someone made a
joke to me they said do you know why we
call them wicked chickens I was like No
And they said because wicked chickens
make the best deviled eggs I was like
okay I am a huge deviled egg fan this is
by far one of the very most delicious
I've ever had the smokiness of the
brisket
and then the brininess of the okra and
then you've got a hit of pimento cheese
which is just perfect it creates this
profile that is a deviled egg but it's
it's so much more you can't get more
classic southern than okra and pimento
cheese the other thing I notice about
your cooking
is it's not just the profile of these
foods that are beautiful but it's so
much about texture a lot of Southern
recipes lack herbs they like acid and
they lack texture a lot of times you'll
see me adding crunchy things and there's
always herbs on everything I do I'm a
big big fan of herbs this is one of my
favorite meals like to eat personally I
ate it for lunch yesterday I was making
it actually it's succotash and then I
love shrimp so much so you top it with
shrimp if there was a dish it kind of
described me it would probably be this
and a Hallmark of Southern Cuisine
perfectly Fried Chicken this was taught
to me all right I can't wait because
then you hear that that's what you want
to hear
oh I mean so juicy and it's it's so
beautifully crispy and fried it's that
marriage where you can't tell where the
skin ends and the crust begins Clark
grew up in Alabama showing an interest
in food at a very early age after
graduating from The Culinary Institute
of America she began cooking in some of
the most respected kitchens in New York
when I was working at Cafe ballude I was
responsible for a family meal which in
our industry is cooking for each other
right I was working under Gavin Cason he
was executive chef and he was like I
want you to cook your food quit cooking
everybody else's cook your food and I
was like
oh okay I gotta cook gumbo I called my
mom's like what's the gummy recipe I
don't remember so she had to type it out
and I cooked gumbo and then it just was
one of those things I would just
remember making the roux in that kitchen
being kind of going this is crazy and
why didn't I ever write this down this
is a moment every single Southern Home
Chef will relate to in this story right
now yeah after her time in New York with
everywhere to choose from
she chose to continue her vision back
home in Dothan Alabama my plan was to go
to New Orleans and so I was coming home
for just a breather because I was burned
out truly I said you know what I'm going
to cater for a little bit because the
caterer that I'd worked for he was my
mentor and he had passed away and there
was this huge void for fine dining
catering here and you know Restless
history didn't leave I ended up getting
here I was fully booked for a year in
about a month and there was just this
wow oh yeah and I had this moment of
like why am I so acting like I'm so
against my town when they are so
unbelievably supportive of me and I
think that that's just where this all
started order up Hayden from there she
opened her restaurant KBC you know when
I was in high school we didn't there was
nothing not a single business here
attracting other businesses to allow
thriving downtown I mean this downtown
area in this Main Street survived the
pandemic yes which is I mean what a
blessing to even be able to say that my
restaurant survived it
um which most of my friends didn't
when the opportunity came to compete on
Top Chef it meant she had to leave
behind her husband and then 10 month old
son for the duration
the sacrifice paid off and Clark took
home the big prize
Kelsey you are top chef
I think for me it was it was a life
lesson more than it was about the food
and and it was just a wonderful
experience because when in your life do
you get to go somewhere and anyone
you've ever respected admired wanted to
learn from is actually doing it with you
for 10 weeks correct
this is your last two and she's used the
exposure she got from her when to spread
the message that southern cooking and
Hospitality should be inclusive of
everyone it is incredibly important for
me at KBC it is always a perfect picture
of what culture should look like and I
think that that's the really cool thing
about this new era we're in is Southern
Hospitality reaching farther than we
thought it would reach is it important
to you that you're a major voice in that
oh it is probably the most important
thing to me the lessons and recipes
she's drawn from Southern Culture are
now the basis for her new cookbook
Southern grit and I've been a collector
of cookbook since I was 12 years old so
that's really what I always think back
on when I see this book now on my shelf
with all the other ones I'm like whoa I
wrote a book wrote a cookbook someone's
reading this you know you don't want a
ton of breading but it's breaded enough
when it's no longer wet the most fun
thing about cooking is teaching people
and hopefully inspiring someone to love
to cook one day okay and for Clark
staying inspired herself is everything
I've even gotten started yet it's how I
really feel to me there's never like a
stopping point you got to keep getting
better and pushing yourself and learning
more and gotta keep going finding a new
thing and then getting really good at it
and that's sort of always my goal being
in the moment being in the moment and
never settling for just now
thank you
what would a Southern food show be
without a bite of fried chicken Jan
Crawford visits some Nashville chicken
joints they put the hot in hot spots
at Hattie B's in Nashville the line goes
down the block for what once was the
city's best kept secret hot chicken I
can't get the large dark plate uh hot
I'm gonna have uh the tenders but I want
them hot it's an addictive combination
of Pleasure and Pain Fried Chicken
doused in cayenne and enough spices to
Make You Sweat Right your eyes are
watering it's because he doesn't do that
let me tell you
yeah I don't know if this is a good
movie that's Father and Son owners Nick
bishop and Nick Jr and I'm going to
start hiccups here in just
they fry up their chicken five ways
including hot damn hot and shut the
cluck up why do you think people want to
eat things that cause them pain
you kind of get hide from it I really
local Legend has it hot chicken started
more than 80 years ago with a family of
this woman Andre Prince Jeffries of
course it started with a woman
of course my great uncle Thornton Prince
being as they say
a womanizer a womanizer who was cheating
on his girlfriend so she decided Revenge
was a dish best served hot and added
some spices to his Fried Chicken if this
woman was angry
so she wanted to let him know so she
dashed something on that chicken
but he liked it
and then that was the beginning
we assume that was the beginning but
it's so sad that we don't know who she
was
but her Legacy lives on great uncle
Thornton started a restaurant using the
girlfriend's recipe and Prince's Hot
Chicken Shack still packs them in number
40
yesterday's there's competition even
from some of the big boys his KFC spicy
Smoky crispy Nashville hot chicken
tenders and for those with a stomach of
Steel there's the death row chicken at
Big shakes
Cooks actually have to wear gas masks
and brave participants in his regular
death row challenge must sign a waiver
you can start
no
it's no gimmick even a few bites burn
but on the night we were there comedian
Chad Ryden kept asking for more chewing
his way to Victory
[Applause]
that's just sad what did it even come
but if he's an amateur what does that
make you fun idiot
and maybe that's why when it comes to
taking the heat Andre Prince Jeffries
the matriarch of the place that started
it all has a confession so you made all
these different
um levels right so which one do you like
mile miles
you like the mild
I can't tolerate anything hot
[Laughter]
oh
coming up what better way to end an
episode than with a sugary snack we'll
take you to a renowned Cafe in New
Orleans next on the dish
foreign
treats usually come at the end of the
meal right but if you've ever been to
New Orleans you know they do things a
little differently in The Big Easy Dana
Jacobson went to the famed Eatery Cafe
Dumont that's serving up Beignets 24
hours a day
[Music]
it's the New Orleans party
open to all
Cafe Dumont it's green and white awning
on Decatur Street as famous as its lines
this lady would like an order of
Beignets can you take care of it for me
here you go thank you which are always
worth the wait come on down I don't
think this venue is going to make it to
the table that's all right that's why
they give you three you have two more to
go when we get there
two more pieces of pastry and powdered
sugar Perfection Cafe Du Man's Signature
Beignets do you know how many calories
are in one I don't think we we don't
count calories in New Orleans that's who
you know we are a Food City and calories
don't count we check them at the board I
like that true or not the Beignets are a
French Quarter staple made and served
fresh
the recipe Basics roll dough cut into
squares tossed into the fryer by hand
then coated in the white stuff is there
a way to make the perfect beignet the
biggest thing is is when you roll it out
and then put it in the oil you want to
make sure the oil is hot enough because
that's what's going to get it to puff up
and the secret to keeping
while I dump it all over myself
when they hunt you put it on and if you
can sift it you know to do something to
get it on a smooth coat and then when
you're biting the Beignets don't breathe
in or breathe out it's just kind of hold
your breath and go for it mmm yep there
goes the sugar
how do you not love that
love that oh my God I know I look
ridiculous right now no not at all and
we like that wood
bites kind of use your fingers a little
bit to separate them I tried my hands at
making some and trying to keep the shape
and found it's not as easy as it looks
put it in but don't put it in with too
much force the oil is very hot
close it and then we just give it a
little push I'm so afraid of that oil I
mean that's good that's what I want
everybody afraid of that oil I missed my
first free throw I can do it it's okay
you'll do better
yeah you did I think I was a little
afraid all right so this oh my gosh very
close or the third but now I understand
why they're all there you go perfect
y'all get everything you need Jay Roman
has been surrounded by Beignets his
entire life his grandfather Hubert
Fernandez bought Cafe Du Monde in 1942.
it's been their family Legacy ever since
I have a 15 month old granddaughter who
is getting ready to eat her first
beignet her mom is you know making her
grow a couple more teeth before she lets
her gather but she will be taking her
first bite of a beignet shortly I'm
thinking about you as a young kid
running around with powdered sugar all
over you this had to be a dream come
true it was perfect we enjoyed you know
it was okay until you get to the old
enough and then they made you sweep the
floor but even working had its benefits
my daughter graduated from Tulane just a
few years ago in an industry known for
keeping those in it away from family at
Cafe Du Monde they continue to be
surrounded by it I got to go to work
with Dad or I got to go to work with my
uncles you know there was something I
would fall forward to doing so I always
tried when my kids were grown up to not
tell them this is what they were going
to do you know let them see for
themselves it is something they wanted
and now now they do I have two children
both of them are working in the business
and doing well with it the family isn't
the only thing intertwined with Cafe Du
Monde so is New Orleans itself people
talk about New Orleans as the Gumbo Pot
you know a mixture of a whole lot of
things and we're just very proud to be
one of the one of the ingredients in
that pot with a history that dates back
to 1862 it's no wonder that's when Cafe
Dumont began as a coffee stand in what's
now the French Market the chicory coffee
it served the same you get today chicory
is the root of the Endive which is a
lettuce and that is roasted and ground
and mixed with the coffee the original
settlers to New Orleans had very short
supplies the trick they used to stretch
their supplies was to add the the Endive
to the coffee it develops its own tastes
in The Taste stuck why did your
grandfather other decide that he had to
buy Cafe Dumont you know he just sat
across the street and again you got to
remember 1942 this wasn't uh it wasn't a
lot of tourism in New Orleans in 1942
but he just had a vision from coffee
stand to Cafe to 10 locations around New
Orleans there's even merchandise and
shipping Nationwide but when in the
Crescent City the original Decatur
Street location is the must visit Spot
Not only for tourists one of the times
Bill Clinton was here in New Orleans and
he was getting ready to leave driving my
kids to school and they were on the
radio saying he's late you know but he
must be going for beignets or Cafe Damon
with that my cell phone rang and it was
my guy downtown saying the Secret
Service is here even with the Celebrity
Status and the growth Jefe Dumont
remains true to its roots we have one
food product you know the Beignets
that's it it's a really good we hope so
but I mean it is it is our only food
product the cafe lay is with milk the
beverages for for a number of years when
when I was growing up we had coffee and
we had cold milk and then over the years
we've expanded a little bit people have
developed taste for iced coffee and
frozen coffee and
but still is a very simple menu
tempting in what this world has become
in food to get the gluten-free beignet
or the
no sugar added you get people with
requests all the time for the
gluten-free and can you sell sandwiches
and can you do this and can you do that
why I mean when we do something well
when you continue to do it and and
people seem to enjoy it you know we just
stick with what you do best I think Cafe
Dumont does that 24 7 364. with the
original location only scheduled to be
closed Christmas Day and while the doors
have been shut by hurricanes like
Katrina and more recently with the
pandemic Roman says opening them back up
is also a part of that family tradition
looking at this and having
all these people enjoy them some for the
first time does that ever get old no
never gets old makes it worth getting up
every morning to see everything all the
happy faces of some of the young
children eating their first beignet and
it makes it all worthwhile
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News I'm Jeff glor
thank you for watching the dish
[Music]